ce week-end était le premier jour des
grands départs de l'été les quatre
autoroutes de notre territoire étaient
fréquentés par les touristes sur la
route des vacances sur les airs de repos
exploitant et gendarmerie étaient
mobilisés pour appeler les bonnes
pratiques pour que le voyage se déroule
en toute sécurité
synonyme de départ en vacances direction
le sud et l'ouest pour beaucoup
d'automobilistes le premier week-end de
chasser croisé en Indre-et-Loire c'est
l'occasion pour la gendarmerie de faire
de la prévention sur l'ère de la longue
vue à monnaie les gendarmes mettent en
garde contre les conduites à risque
conduite sous l'emprise stupéfiants les
conduites sous une vitesse trop élevée
les conduites aussi on va parler
d'infraction grave génératrice
d'accident donc donc voilà c'est de
rappeler toutes ces infractions là et
toutes ces conduites là qui ne sont pas
bonnes et qu'on essaye de bannir et en
plus aujourd'hui on met le vernis
vacances c'est-à-dire qu'on va parler
des surcharges on va parler des des
temps de route à respecter donc pour
faire une pause toutes les deux heures
pour Vinci autoroute qui gère le tronçon
les conséquences des conduites à risque
et du manque de vigilance des usagers de
la route sont parfois tragiques pour les
agents qui interviennent après un
accident il y a en moyenne plus d'un
véhicule d'intervention heurter chaque
semaine par des usagers de l'autoroute
donc nous luttons contre ce phénomène et
notamment en rappelant ici sur l'aire de
Tours la longue-vue et sur toutes les
autres aires à nos clients qu'il faut
respecter la règle du corridor de
sécurité donc cette règle elle est assez
simple il s'agit de ralentir et changer
de voix ce décaler lorsqu'on voit du
personnel en intervention ça permet de
maintenir tout le monde en sécurité
règle de bon usage de l'autoroute la
mise en place d'un corridor de sécurité
est entré dans le code de la route en